neuer wlan rekord so schnell konnten
daten noch nie drahtlos übertragen
werden die terahertz strahlung macht es
möglich
zehnmal schneller als zukünftige 5g
mobile netzwerke gekommen baki von
pflanzen weg erinnert ihr euch noch an
die live technologie die arizona state
university berichtete dass man mit der
leser live variante eine bis zu 1000 mal
schnellere verbindung herstellen könnte
als dieses wlan haken an der sache
empfänger und sender müssen eine
sichtverbindung haben jetzt haben
forscher der hiroshima universität in
japan einen revolutionären weg gefunden
mehrere terabyte pro sekunde drahtlos
übertragen zu können
bisher reden wir bei kabellosen
übertragungsraten von mega bit oder
allenfalls wenigen gigabit pro sekunde
aber jetzt nähern wir uns einer
übertragungsrate von therapeut pro
sekunde und das in nur einem einzigen
kommunikationskanal so minow fukushima
von der hiroshima universität mit der
sogenannten terahertzstrahlung erfolgten
die wissenschaftler einen 100 gigabit
pro sekunde rasanten datentransfer kanal
das bedeutet dass hier knapp drei dvds
pro sekunde übertragen wurden und ein
ganzes terabyte nur eine minute und 20
sekunden für die übertragung benötigt
hätte wahnsinn
bisher gab es noch keine trank mit die
kompakt und preiswert genug waren das
terahertz frequenzspektrum zu nutzen es
gab die terahertz lück unsere
herkömmlichen glasfaserleitungen sein
den vorstand zufolge aufgrund des
leistungsverlustes innerhalb der leitung
ungeeignet für anwendungen die echtzeit
reaktion erfordern heute habe man daher
lediglich die wahl zwischen hohen
übertragungsraten mit glasscheibe auf
der einen seite oder aber geringeren
latenzzeiten reaktionszeiten mit weniger
durchsatz mittels mikrowellen der von
ihnen entwickelte transmitter können uns
durch exzellente leistungen in beiden
punkten
die entscheidungen zwischen glasfaser
oder mikrowellen abnehmen schon in zwei
jahren auf der welt telekommunikations
konferenz soll über den frequenzbereich
der terahertz
mit gesprochen werden wird diese
technologie im großen stil vertrieben
werden aber millionen prozesse in
unserer netz abhängigen welt
beschleunigt und nahezu in echtzeit
ausgeführt und darf mit extrem hohen
datenraten es wird die kommunikation auf
der erde weiter beschleunigen und ganz
neue anwendungen möglich machen entsteht
dabei nicht auch ein großes
sicherheitsrisiko nicht könnte mehr
aufgehalten werden
wäre alles viel zu schnell wenn euch das
thema cyberkriminalität interessiert
könnt ihr hier auf ein video zum
cyberkrieg klicken und wenn euch dieses
video gefallen hat aber nur dann lass
mir gerne ein abo dafür auch da klicken
und den klick auf die glocke nicht
vergessen und was ist eure meinung zu
immer schnelleren netzen kommen wir
irgendwann mit der datenflut nicht mehr
klar lasst uns in den kommentaren
darüber diskutieren und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran